are
live i guess
um so hello everybody
uh we're pretty excited to be here as we
start i want to introduce you to uh cord
core nielsen is of course the artist for
god's dog
um
so i'm really happy that he can be here
it's been a long journey for us to kind
of yeah
sorry about that echo oh yeah uh i mean
it it might echo because of the delay
actually you might so you i might end up
having to put on earphones uh if maybe
or
or mute the mute the youtube and then at
least have zoom clean yeah all right
sorry about that so we're figuring this
out it's actually the first time i think
i do a live uh video with two people and
so figuring that out has been fun as you
know my my uh my boomer status here um
and so yeah so like i said court it's
been a long journey we've been working
together uh we've been through a lot
court is also a young father you know
he's had all these issues he's moved
he's had all these things going on in
his life
but here we are we're pretty excited the
um crowdfunding
has been stellar like it's just been
taking off in a really exciting way
and uh as i mentioned several times one
of the purposes we have one of the goals
we have is that we can raise enough
enough funds so that cord can do this
full time and then we can start pumping
out god's dogs uh god's dog books you
know in in a timely manner so cord uh
say hello to everybody it's good to have
you
hello everybody it's good to be here
and so uh i wanted you guys to get a
sense of uh we're definitely gonna be
more in the chat than we usually are in
these types of things um but i wanted
you guys to meet courtney i want to tell
a bit the story of how we started and
just how it's been to put this together
um
and so
i met cord was it in 2018 or 2017 like
right at the beginning wasn't it
yeah it was very either late 2017 or
early 2018.
yeah so it was right when jordan
peterson was kind of
pure saying before his book before all
of that
uh and maybe tell me tell them how you
why is it you reached out to me how that
started you remember
yeah so i was obsessed with
uh jordan's work and uh especially the
biblical series and i was trying to
make a sort of like a research comic
where i was trying to lay out all of his
ideas and things i was learning about
genesis etc
and
i noticed a pattern in what was it
i was looking at the flood and the noaa
story and i noticed a pattern of
the names of
the fathers in the lineage from seth and
the lineage from kane and i noticed that
those names were starting to become more
and more similar the closer they got to
the flood
um like from noah's
father grandfather great fan great
grandfather and tubal kane's same and
their names were getting closer and
closer and i just thought that was
strange and i reached out to you to ask
if this was a pattern you had seen
um
i don't even really remember what your
response was but in a way it didn't
matter what i responded because i just
remember you saying he's doing a comic
book and so yeah obviously i have a love
for art and i'm always interested in
meeting good artists
so i remember
asking you about the project and i think
you even sent me some images or at least
there were some images available of what
you were doing
um and i asked you for your page and
then i went to see the work you were
doing
and i always had i've been for years to
be honest like for years since since
2010 or 2011 i've been trying to think
of ways to get the gods dog story out
there matsuri and both of us matu and i
um and so looking for comic artists
thinking of how we could do this so i
went on your
website and there were two comics and
they were both like a weird
a weird jimmy hendrix like a weird rip
representation of a jimi hendrix song
but like in a medieval setting and so
one was like a like this kind of
sorcerer character like alchemist in his
lab it was um purple haze and he steps
out of his lab and there was another one
that was with like these wolves in the
forest um and to be honest it didn't
really matter what the content was but
the i i really saw that the
composition
of the panels and the way that the flow
of the story
uh was going i think they were just two
pages each but i thought oh my goodness
this guy
he could he could totally do this uh and
so yeah so i asked you if you would be
willing to read the screenplay
yeah i remember you you said i have a
project that could be a comic book and
maybe we'll work together sometime in
the future and i just kind of put that
in my back pocket and then i kept
working on this project that i was
trying to work on and it was too big and
it was driving me crazy trying to like
write a research comic about
genesis it was so i just i was like
forget this one i'm gonna reach out to
jonathan and say
well i'll do that book
and and it was interesting because that
one book that you were doing with the
jordan stuff it was not how can i say it
it wasn't a visual idea
right it was a more conceptual idea and
your work is so good visually like it
the the comp it's the composition the
contrast the way that you put together
the the characters that's what that's
what's really powerful about your work
and so it probably wasn't the best thing
suited for you but god's talk was
definitely the best thing that was uh
suited for your uh your talent so tell
tell people like what you know when you
did end up reading the screenplay what
did you think like what was your what
was your impression
uh the first time i read it uh my first
impression was this is way bigger than
than i was expecting um and yeah it was
huge
but it was really rich
i can remember right where i was
the night that i read it
and it just left a big impression on me
i knew that it was going to take a lot
but i really wanted to be a part of it
um
and so then
go ahead i mean we we just basically
that already like right at the beginning
i remember you read it and you said okay
you know i don't know what this means
like i don't know exactly what this is
gonna lead to but you know i wanna i
wanna try this i wanna do this
um and so obviously we realized that it
would make no sense to fit this into one
book like it would just be way too much
um
and so and so yeah so we just started
working at cutting it into pieces but it
was mostly you that did that work if i
remember
yeah i just i i found
uh
i found parts in the big script or
screenplay that seemed like good places
to break it up
um
and that would still feel like
self-contained stories for each novel
yeah as close as we could um yeah and so
so that's so that's how it really
started and i also had done
like several drawings at the outset
to you know because at first the idea
was to make it as a screenplay but we
really we still did want a world build
so i drew all these characters and the
scenes the different like for example uh
there's like this city of giants and
there's all these these different uh
characters so i did these drawings but
um yeah but i i'm not a con like i'm not
really comic book artist i think i was
looking through my um i was looking
through my sketchbook and i found that i
tried to do like about 10 pages of the
story um but yeah it's not
it's not as good as yours chord oh
that's all i can say
i mean it's okay you know but it's not
it's not as good it's definitely not as
good as yours uh so i'm really happy
that you were willing to do this
well thank you yeah it's been a pleasure
all right guys so this this is your
chance like i've got people in the chat
you know i am really going to we're
really going to uh to be open to uh to
the chat this time so if you have
questions if you have things that you
were curious about um
then then then this is the place so
somebody asks will the vod be posted i
don't know what that is do you know what
that is what's a vod
so we don't know what that is so sadly
we have no idea um
and so uh yeah so
the the the idea that we we started
working with was
basically cord worked on all the uh
sketches you know he worked on uh first
of all we laid out the entire book like
during doing all the layouts for the
entire book and we even had i remember i
don't know if you remember we had the
idea that we should do the all the books
first that we should do all the sketches
for all the books first because we
wanted to have like a massive
uh like a massively coherent uh project
but man that was just it was just not
reasonable it was just too much
yeah and you had the better idea at that
point we had finished the first one and
almost the second one
uh and you said we've got to start this
thing because the second one could
change depending on how the success of
the first one
does and uh
it was the right decision so i started
drawing pretty quickly and
[Music]
here we are i guess here we are yeah and
so the
the big thing that's important for
people to understand too is that uh
is that the um
the book
how can i say this the story that we
have the screenplay so we wrote this
screenplay when we were very naive uh
back we started in like 2008 2007 2008
we finished in 2010
uh and we thought like we're gonna send
this to all these hollywood studios uh
and you know we're gonna have this done
as a movie but that wasn't gonna happen
so it was requested like it was
recommended by a script scouting agency
and it was it was like it was uh
requested by studios we even tried to
like send it to mel gibson which just
shows us how naive we were at the time
um but
ultimately it didn't work but in
creating the process of refining it into
a screenplay we also had to
remove huge amounts of story like all
these threads that were making it richer
and more
and fuller we had to remove and so
you know one of the things we'd like to
do it depends on how well the book does
is to make this
into even more than what it was before
that is add more of the threads together
make this an even more epic story um so
this is something that we're looking at
doing all right let me see i've got some
questions here in the the chat uh
someone asked a technical question will
the signed pics of saint christopher
beside on the back
and so i've had several people ask that
and and i think that's fine if that's
what people want i don't know if that's
really that's what people want but i
understand i understand that some people
said they wanted sign of the back so
that they could kind of use it um you
know in their as a in their icon praying
corner or something like that so i'm not
i haven't decided for sure it'll be hard
to do like specifics for specific people
especially if we've got like a thousand
a thousand things to deal with but uh
but i'm i'm considering it let's say
hopefully you can always get an unsigned
print you know uh if ever we end up
signing it on the front it's also also a
possibility i think it's it's like 10 or
15 so
that might be it yeah
and the uh the vaod question uh people
are correct uh correcting this thing
it's video on demand so i guess that
means will this video be posted
afterwards yeah definitely it'll just
stay on my channel and so that that will
be that you can just watch it later if
you want um
all right so christopher
simberski asked does the story swell out
to the edges of the world and then snap
back to the into the center
so the best way to really understand the
way the story works is that it's really
about the relationship between the
center and the periphery and the the
stakes of both and uh the let's say the
advantages and the disadvantages of both
and how they play on each other and so
it you mostly have to understand it as
uh
scaling up of the same problem right so
it starts with
the a smaller version of the story where
it's like saint christopher encountering
these characters in the wilderness and
then it becomes something like i said on
the nick with the nicholas kotar
discussion in the last book it's going
to be something like you know the
byzantine army fighting an army of
giants which i'm sure cord is super
excited about doing something like that
i think that that that scene
particularly made me reach out to you
and say i don't think i can do this like
at all there's no way that this will be
done but you uh you talked me into it so
we shall see but it's also i think it's
also something that we're going to work
up to and so you know i think that also
at the at the beginning you obviously
had to um acclimate uh acclimate
yourself to the characters acclimate
yourself to the specific style of the of
the comic and so i'm sure that by the
end when we're ready you'll just be
zipping through you know massive combat
fighting scenes between armies of uh of
giants and with the leviathan you know
taking up some of that space so i'm sure
it'll be totally fine no i yeah i mean i
was being a little facetious because as
i'm as we're getting to the end of the
book and i'm finishing up the final
pages i'm actually starting to really
get in the groove of
drawing how i like to draw the book i'm
figuring it out so
um i'm happy to keep going and i think
it will only get better so that's for
sure it's already gotten better from the
first page until the last pages you can
see
like just an improvement in fluidity you
know like you are you the composition i
think is is as good all through but
towards the end you can really feel more
fluidity in the the character so that's
awesome thank you thank you
um and so someone asked can you venerate
the dog-headed depiction and so
you know i would say that you should be
cautious about that uh it's probably
better to
to avoid it or to ask your priest you
know your own spiritual authority what
they think of that you know um
so it's a tricky question because it's a
controversial icon and so i would rather
say no ask your priest and uh that's the
best way to
to to deal with that
all right someone says who are chords
artistic influences and what are your
thoughts on the future of the graphic
novel medium for visual storytelling
um
my the two visual influences that come
to mind are jeff smith
who created bone
and mike mignola of hellboy um there are
a few in there but i really like
um
[Music]
i don't know
very uh like a visual
graphic simplicity
uh strong
black and white work uh with a lot of
solid black ink shapes
[Music]
as far as the future of the graphic
novel medium it's funny i've kind of
pulled away from like the world of
comics
especially in the last few years i don't
follow a lot but
as a medium i think graphic novels are
are
are great i mean they're the net they're
just shy of maybe what you could do with
animation uh in film
um but as
i think
it would be interesting more to focus on
what kind of stories
would be told in the future
um and i think that's a lot of what
jonathan and i are hoping to to have an
effect on with this story yeah i think
that's really a really important aspect
is that the way that we're thinking
about this is not only just about
this story
uh and if you watch also my interview
with nicholas you'll see that we're
hinting at the idea that we really want
to inaugurate
kind of a new
i mean it sounds arrogant but it's like
a new era of storytelling we want to
we want to give people the possibility
of telling these types of stories which
is to unabashedly dive into our own
stories our own mythology our own um
you know our own biblical world and and
do it in a way that isn't
that isn't flaky that isn't moralistic
but is just the celebration like the
story the story is really like an
adventure story it's like a you know
it's like lord of the rings or some some
other adventure story but it's a
celebration of that whole kind of
biblical lore and biblical world um and
it's funny that you know cord mentioned
um mike mignola which is which was also
one of the reasons why i really loved
his work because i appreciate uh mignola
but not only that
there's something about the what we're
doing which is almost like uh almost
like an anti-hellboy is a good way to
understand it which is i was thinking of
that today it was it's almost like uh
like if this god's dog world gets
expanded it's almost as if mike mignola
believed in some of the stuff he wrote
about or you know what i mean is like
it has that heart but then also
it's it wouldn't be cynical or ironic
exactly and so
that's what mignola does is he dives
into all of kind of these ancient
legends and kind of esoteric
christianity you know and arthurian
legend and all these these kind of
medieval uh legends that exist in the
west but he does it in a way that like
like court said is kind of cynical
materialistic
um and also the character of hellboy is
a very is a very disturbing character
because he's supposed to bring about the
end of the world there's all this
tension that's there and so
our story is in the in a similar world
it's not exactly the same it's in a
similar world but it's not a it doesn't
have any of the materialism and cynicism
that you find so hopefully weekend
weekend yeah i mean that's uh that's
hopefully we can be part of that change
you know and it's not just us like like
we've been saying it's about it's all
it's about everybody you know we want to
make it possible to tell these stories
and so that other people can do it as
well
all right so let's see some of these
questions so so people are saying so now
the questions are really starting to uh
to to kind of
um so we've got a few super chats i
guess so god dawg god's dog exists
meaning wave exists
god's dog meaning wave when
i don't know man ask ask the meaning way
people you know they they can uh
they can decide um so the golden thread
for five dollars said do you think
attention from film studios might return
after the books are published you you
essentially have a script and a
beautiful storyboard now and so you know
there's a lot of stuff happening behind
the scenes you know that you that it's
we don't talk about a lot but that is
floating around so if you look in the
chat you will see that dirt paul robbins
is in the uh the chat and dirt paul
robbins neil degrade is and his wife and
and his his group they're putting out a
movie very soon we'll have him on the
channel very soon called the queen of
queen of the night which is going to be
a a kind of fairy tale black and white
fairy tale story
and so we're all in communication
hoping to create enough buzz around
these types of projects so something
like god's dog something like queen of
the night in order to
to attract
or at least not even attract the actual
studios that already exist but to have
enough energy to consolidate talents and
people that are that are around the
industry that are good and uh bring them
together to uh to yeah to reach that
next level because
because things like netflix we can
already see that the ideological bent of
it is becoming so strong that
the the further we go in the future the
more there will be room for
for competition and for um
and for better stories to say so
um
and so hopefully and so like for example
chord one of the things we've been
talking about is that at some point cord
would like to be more like an artistic
director where we have several projects
and he's working on these different
projects and we're putting out different
things and so there's a lot of stuff
going on you know what you see is always
the tip of the of the iceberg you know
i've been talking with richard roland i
was talking to him today
and he also has worked on several novels
and stories
and so we're going to take some time to
look at them and see how they can fit in
this
in this puzzle but um but yeah there's
there's a lot of possibility there's
really no
there's no limit to what we can do
all right so michael archangel says did
the byzantines really fight giants and
it's just hidden from the pages of
history by the
nwo uh
i'm sure they did i don't know i don't
know the story though but in our comic
book they definitely will be fighting
giants um
all right so let's see what we got here
[Music]
i'm not really good at this
uh so hellboy and saint christopher
crossover who knows
now i i
have to draw that probably
that would be definitely that would be
cool uh it'll be interesting to see how
people react because it's a
you know i was thinking about a chord
like the first book
is super christian i mean when i look at
it now because especially also because
we at the beginning of the the story we
have this ancient hymn this ancient hymn
of saint from the syrian which is
perfect because it talks about monsters
coming out of the deep you know in the
light shining on them and uh
and it's perfect and there's like a
there's a there's one panel in the book
which oh man i wish i could show people
right now there's one panel in the book
which i think is the actual
synthesis of the entire story of god's
dog that it's at the end of the chant it
says something like for we have found a
savior and then we hear dog barking and
the bark is like underneath that that
that text and i was like man cory's
nailing it in terms of like the the kind
of the hidden symbolism that's in there
yeah
well i it
it had a lot to do with uh you know
listening to a lot of your work and then
uh
it was just all there in the screenplay
i think just in the subtext as i read it
so
every page
every page that is in this book is
pretty much exactly how it kind of
appeared in my head the first time i
read the the screenplay
so it was all just kind of there as i
was reading it
that's super interesting yeah and so
what is the because it's what's
interesting is that some of the things
are explicitly there in the screenplay
and then some of the elements are really
elements that you added you know uh like
for example the design of the swords
like there's a there's a design of saint
george's sword and when you showed it to
me i was like this is so obvious like
you really totally nailed it in terms of
making it this fractal symbolism uh and
so yeah so i mean tell me a bit about
the that experience of like of going in
and then seeing these images uh appear
to you
i don't know it's hard to explain it
just kind of happens you know
this is i mean you could ask my wife
about me trying to explain symbolism and
it's pretty much impossible it's you
know it's just more something that i see
in my mind but
this with the sword
just it was pretty obvious to me that
the the handle and the pommel of
george's sword was the same as
saint simeon's pillar
um
with the light at the top and the the
snake around the
pillar and then at the base of the sword
um
which is it's also another image of the
cosmic mountain and at the base i put
thorns on the uh
the top of the scabbard
um and then below that hang the skins
the garments of skin
it's basically like the image of
everything that i drew it's just the
image it's like and it was it was even
before that i drew that image of
everything uh it was implied in the
story like
there were smaller versions of it that
i'd drawn but when i saw your design for
the sword i was like man this guy this
is i i i was saying i could not regret
you know that it's you who's doing this
you beat me to that image of everything
but i'm glad that you did because i kept
thinking i have to draw this because i
have this image in my head and it's this
cosmic image of everything and it maps
onto this pillar and this sword and
everything and then you drew yours and
it's like okay good it's been done no i
didn't let that idea go because it's not
it's not like you said it's not it's not
like it's my idea it's more it's the
desire to kind of pull all of these
threads together into one uh into one uh
one place let's say um all right so
somebody asked how much of the story has
changed from what was written 10 years
ago
and so with the first book that you're
going to read
very little has changed almost
it's almost exactly the story
that that is that was there in the
original screenplay except for one
detail unless i'm wrong you can tell me
if there's another detail chord but the
one detail is in the original screenplay
we introduced the the giants as
characters much later in the story so
you see these giants but you don't
interact with them as characters and the
one thing that we decided to do was to
introduce them right away in the first
book and so so now so now in the first
book there's there are a few scenes
where you see them and then there's
finally a scene where you meet you know
the important giants that will be there
in the rest of the story and this is
something which now we've decided to
follow through
the other books as well and so once once
we get through the hype of of of this
we're going to go back into the second
book that's already started to be
sketched but we're go we're going to
interweave the giants more
let's say in a fuller way so that they
become characters all through the story
and i think it's it's actually quite a
it's actually quite a good addition
because i didn't tell you this chord but
several people who read the original uh
like the full a few people have read the
full comic and many of them have said oh
man that last scene when we see they're
like i want to see more of of those i
want to see more of them so they get
really excited about that
good i felt the same way when i drew it
right as i finished that last page it
gave us that feeling of oh just we need
more of this so
it'll be good yeah and i think i
remember you writing me and i hadn't
seen the image yet and you said you said
i think this is the best character
introduced that i've done yet and i was
like when i saw it i'm like yeah this is
awesome
so that's going to be great um and so
somebody asked me does saint simian bash
giants and demons with a pillar
now uh matt in a way you know but not
we're definitely not gonna see him
wielding a pillar in his arms you know
all right someone asked okay so this is
a good question and this is awesome
because so someone asked why a
palindrome for the title
and what's awesome about the palindrome
is that we obviously thought of it as a
palindrome but then cord made it into
more than a palindrome it's like someone
actually said there's like an actual
technical
word for what it is because it's like
it's both a palindrome going left to
right but it also
the the g becomes like the the the last
g becomes like the top g uh
and so so yeah anyway it's but the idea
is that this is
you know when when matsir and his book
and i in the videos we talk about the
the flip
you know this kind of double inversion
thing so you have to understand that
this is what this book is ultimately
going to be about and it's a it's about
that in many ways it's about it even in
terms of
one of the things that i've said you
might maybe people haven't paid
attention to this but one of the things
i've said is that there's something
about the ark which is lowly there's
something about the ark which is
not
something that is lofty it's a it's a
boat full of animals and that for
example the the arc that was the um
dante's um comedy was written in a
popular italian it was written in a
popular way that was like the most
accessible
to anybody and there's something about
the comic medium which i think makes it
possible to create something like that
i'm not saying we're going to create
something as awesome as dante but the
desire to create something which goes
all the way to the bottom of culture but
is ultimately going to kind of hide in
it some of the the highest mysteries you
could say um and so there's a meta
question about it which is also like so
flipping the monster
uh flipping the uh the the idea of this
kind of popular art form into something
more precious so there's a lot of stuff
going on in the in the story that are
related to this uh this palindrome i
know if you have some thoughts on that
court yeah
to me the palindrome also has that it
reflects the margins to the center you
know
and that they're they kind of flow in
and out of each other from center to
margin etc
um so even when i saw the title i
thought that it was a which i think a
good title is of an encapsulation of a
whole story but the fact that the title
was a palindrome just kind of reinforced
that for this story yeah
and it's not and it's also not something
that it's a
it's a pun that has been made before
like we didn't obviously didn't make
that up uh but but we we're trying to
kind of go as far as we can into the the
meaning of what that is and into the
because
the idea is also that
you know the dog is the upside down of
god and you you've probably heard if you
listen to if you if you listen to
subversive people you've probably heard
them say subversive things about that
and kind of make it into a joke but yeah
so that's what we're going to do but
we're going to turn the joke back return
the joke back
all right let's see what else we got um
all right so let's see
okay so somebody says is the symbolism
explaining book worth buying how deep is
it and so
i'll be honest with you like
matsir's article
is going to be enough to be to have it
worth being bought you know it's like
metier hasn't published anything since
uh the language of creation and people
don't understand that the language of
creation is like an it's like an abc of
what matsuya thinks it's not at all
coming any close to his capacity for
thinking and symbolic thinking and so
what i'm hoping is that people in this
text which is going to be a text on the
relationship between samson and the
cherub and the flaming sword which is
like just thinking about that it sounds
awesome so he's go so that just that
text is going to be amazing and it's
going to be related to
these things in the story because these
things are all kind of in the story the
cherub the flaming sword the
relationship between you know purity and
excess uh let's say uh
the idea of of too much purity and too
much chaos you could say all of this is
now is being played out in the story so
that it all obviously is going to be
awesome in itself the other thing which
is going to be added is i wrote two
articles on saint christopher which
were written on the orthodox art journal
those articles have were the most
popular that
that have we've ever written and if you
write you know like the dog-headed icon
of saint christopher on google that's
probably the one of the first if not the
first result that's going to come up but
i wrote two
two uh
sections of that article but i never
wrote the third one and the reason why i
never wrote the third one is because i
felt nobody was ready for the things
that i had to say in the third article
but now with everything that's happened
in the past few years with
with lord of spirits and all these
things that are that are that are out
there i feel like now i can finally
write that third part of the article
which will be in there so apart from
that they'll also be uh of course
there'll be sketches from uh chord
sketchbook how he developed the ideas
they'll also be my own sketches that i
created
you know 10 years ago some of the
drawings that for the designs and uh and
a whole bunch of other good stuff but uh
yeah i definitely think it's worth it um
obviously if it wasn't worth it we also
wouldn't be putting it out
i don't even know what are there other
things that you wanted to put into the
because we haven't yet put it together
but it's gonna happen very soon
uh no no i just look forward to putting
it together i think that there's a lot
of material to put there with my
drawings your drawings those articles
and uh
that matthew's article as well and
there's a lot of stuff too that we'll be
saving for later because we when we
wrote the screenplay we wrote something
called
the the god's dog source book and the
the swords book was basically
going through all the different patterns
which were behind the story and so you
could read god's dog just read it in an
hour or like you know whatever an hour
and a half and and uh get the story and
find it entertaining but there's a lot
of other stuff going on behind the
scenes in the backgrounds
uh you know there are patterns that some
people might not see at first but
so we wrote that as at the outset as a
uh as a kind of source book to to kind
of help people understand it and so
we'll be injecting some of that
in there as well
um and so so that will probably be
happening
all right and so someone says is mature
writing other things at the moment yes
he is writing other things um
um he's writing several things kind of
at the same time but he's also he's also
setting himself up in a in a way he's
living he's moved away from the city
he's bought some land you know he's
starting to uh to do agriculture and
farming uh and so he's really taking
that route of uh
let's say getting ready for the worst
you could say and so that's also
something that matthew's dealing with
[Music]
lots of people asking for an animated
series that would be awesome like i
think that the style too is perfect for
that you know i think that would be
that'd be wonderful you know i think
that definitely could i think at this
point as we kind of see it develop it it
would be better as a series and as a
movie anyways
yeah yeah
definitely um
all right so who did you write this book
for are the secular folks going to hop
on board with this do you think
um and so like i said when we wrote it
we submitted it to a secular script
scouting agency uh and it was requested
by hollywood um
hollywood studios and so the idea is
that i think i think the book is
accessible to everybody uh
and it's not it's
it's definitely in the christian world
but it's not a christian story in the
kind of
same way that we think think that it
like i said it really is an adventure
story with character arcs and and uh and
cosmic stakes and all of this
um and so i'm hoping that
both christians and secular people will
be willing to uh to read it you know but
i think that that might also take a
little bit of time
you know we might need to get our our
street creds
uh down for for uh for a bit
before it really gains the steam that i
think it could have um but i but i do
really think that uh that that's
possible
um
jess smiley my friend
asks uh shout out to jess by the way
he's a great illustrator he's got he's
made a lot of kids books and stuff
um
he asks what tools and materials and
methods uh so
most of the book was drawn completely
physically pencil on paper and then ink
on paper
and then colored by felipe cartin who we
should probably mention too he did such
a good job
but then the final
20 pages or so were penciled digitally
and then printed and inked physically uh
just using a brush pen and various
pens
yeah so that's why if you go on the the
gods dog
on the god sub crowdfunding you can buy
original artwork you can you can
actually get some of the pages because
they're they were just drawn on paper
most of them and so yeah and they're
great i was very lucky i have the best
ones
corn was very kind enough to give me the
best pages and so i have those i'll
probably be putting them up very soon i
just need to have them framed and then
i'll and i'll put them up um
all right someone asked christians the
way lord of the rings is christian so
this is an interesting question because
uh
the thing about lord of the rings which
is interesting but which is also a
little strange is that on the one hand
it's like this fully cosmic realized
cosmic world that has you know all the
kind of hierarchies and has different um
all the different aspects of a
traditional mythology a traditional
cosmology but it's not christian
and
because of that it it was able to be
popular because i think if it had been
christian people would have resisted it
and reacted to it
um
but the gamble we're making
is in a way a bigger gamble like the
gamble we're making is that our story is
fully in the christian mythological
frame
like it's completely in there so it's
like it's
it's all about you know the paradise and
the
the giants and the angels and uh all
these things that and then some elements
that we've
that are there in the bible but that
we've kind of emphasized like the
garments of skin for example uh and
other elements as well and so this is
the gamble we're making but i do think
in a certain way
it's so funny to say that but i think in
a certain way the world is more ready
for that now
than it was in the time of of token
and part of the reason why they're ready
is because of things like hellboy
and uh and and uh neil gaiman's you know
like good omens and constantine and all
these
surprisingly very kind of anti-christian
or subversively
subversive stories using christian
tropes they've set the stage for people
to kind of understand stories in that
world
well and
you can just see it in in the shows that
are on tv right now on netflix that i
think that the world is so hungry for
enchantment again and you can you can
feel the longing in certain shows like
my kids watch this one called hilda and
it's all about this sort of fantasy
world
but you can feel that the creators they
want to believe so badly in these trolls
and fairies etc
and and that's just one example you know
and so what if you do start telling
stories that are enchanted and rich that
from a creative entertainment standpoint
they make you want to believe in
something but it actually
is something you can believe in
yeah
definitely
so someone asked a good question someone
says uh
are you concerned that explaining the
pattern explicitly will diminish its
power in experiencing a story and so
this is really in a way this is a risk
uh and you're totally right about it now
the way that i see it is that we're
explaining it as a jump start mechanism
it's like a way to to jump start the
machine but there's definitely a lot of
stuff that
will remain unexplained and that are
unexplained and if you read it there's a
lot of stuff that we're not going to
explain to you so it is in a way a way
just a way to jumpstart the
the capacity to see the value of it um
and also you know you guys like here
like let's be honest like the people
that are here there's something like uh
you're kind of like the first
you know the first how what's that term
they use like the the people that
perceive the trend first right the the
the first triers or whatever they call
them and so there's a way in which
you're like you're going to be this
elite which understands it more than
others but then if we're able to make it
gather a lot of interest you know by the
time we
have it in like sunday schools or in
schools or like in libraries or in
bookstores then
then those people won't have those
explanations they'll just have the story
look hopefully there'll be enough of the
the possibility of that story for people
to kind of to to get it to the level
they need to get it let's say
early adopters yes that is the term
thank you brian bob that's the right one
that's the right one
all right let's see what else we got
someone says is it christian the way
loris is christian caldora asked that
yes that's actually a really good
example and you know when i read loris
um i was super excited because i felt
like i felt like even when we wrote
god's dog 10 years ago
at some point it dawned on me that like
nobody was ready for the story that
people just weren't ready for it like
there wasn't enough padding there for it
to land properly you know in the in the
culture
uh but then when i read loris i felt
like oh man this is great like this is
actually showing me
giving me hope for what's possible
um and then since we've started doing it
it's crazy that lord of spirits has
appeared since we started doing this i
know if you heard cord yesterday uh when
i did the discussion with nicholas kotar
he was saying you know he was sure that
we had changed the story because of the
lord's spirits and i was like no it's
just all coming together
yeah yeah i did hear that
so that was pretty amazing yeah so
everybody's excited to be set to be told
that they're early adopters and
trailblazers but i really think that
look i just i'm being totally sincere
when i say that
this is the future like not necessarily
this book you know but what i mean is
that the world is being re-enchanted
this is this is the future and uh
you know we need to to take uh we need
to place ourselves in it and we need to
shine in it because
there's a lot of dark reenchantment
happening at the same time um and so we
have to we have to be able to present
the best stories and the ones that are
the most
that are the most convincing and so
this this story is in a way it's a kind
of trick it's the saint christopher
trick because
it presents a lot of
like it presents a lot of darkness at
the outset like a lot of strangeness and
a lot of monstrosity uh and then it
leads people into a surprise let's say
so but you'll have to be you'll still
have to be patient the one thing i'm
worried about and i'll say this publicly
is that you know because we talk about
it like this and i'm worried that when
people get the book they're gonna read
it and then they're gonna they're gonna
expect like a full
epic story but it's really just the
beginning of the story like it's not
just the beginning but it really is like
the first chapter where everything all
the stakes kind of get set up the
characters get set up you know we meet
all the all the different elements that
are going to play themselves out um and
it's a little bit like a little
microcosm let's say of the bigger story
but it's not it's not the full story so
know you so you're not gonna see
uh it's important to understand you're
not gonna see armies of byzantine
soldiers fighting giants yet there will
be some there are there is definitely
some some conflict but not not not that
one yet
no we found a way to work some action
into this one too yeah well there are
dra there is the dragons the giants are
there there's uh there is there is some
action but uh yeah it's it's it's gonna
be like a progressive um
it's gonna be a
a story where the sk the the
scales up you know and then the the the
different um
elements are just getting bigger as the
story goes
um
all right and so yeah go for it
uh the youngest age that the book would
be appropriate for
um
i did my best to i mean
let me let me put it another way there's
there's a little bit of
you know kind of
blood sword action but
i i
try to stay away from any anything too
gory or
too graphic so i don't i don't think
that it would be
inappropriate for
what do you think jonathan i i think 10
year old like i honestly i think i think
this could be read by 10 year olds i
think that under 10 years old people the
the
kids might not find it
interesting let's say but i think it's
starting at 10 years old like when you
have that capacity to kind of tell the
story but there's definitely nothing i
don't think there's anything
inappropriate about the story and
there's nothing
there's nothing there's nothing they
haven't seen watching uh you know
watching their cartoons or whatever so
um yeah so it but i but there's also
other things for
you know for more kind of seasoned
readers that are there in the the
background and happening at the same
time
all right so santa claus exists god's
dog christmas special anyone this is
andrew uh
komarami for two dollars and so it's
funny that you say that because
one of the future projects or one of the
projects that i have that i've actually
started writing uh a while ago but that
i kind of paused when you know you know
when i could see that god's dog wasn't
yet going anywhere is actually a uh a
kind of mythological version of the the
story of saint nicholas where we bring
where we merge saint nicholas and santa
claus together and so so that that if if
this goes well like if this this moves
like these types of stories
are going to start flowing that's for
sure
so if you yeah if you see questions in
the in the chat court go for it you know
i'm just i'm just kind of scrolling here
holly fischer asks if i'm overwhelmed by
the drawing yet to come
[Music]
um
no
but i would like to be in a position to
where
it just doesn't take so long because
there's a lot of drawing
and
i put a lot of effort into it um and i
love doing it so no i'm not overwhelmed
by it it's just a matter of
how well we do and what the future holds
yeah and it's also i think that one of
the things that has made it overwhelming
is also the fact that
you were doing this but you also had so
many other things going on at the same
time so it's you know it's like the
weight of having a full-time job and and
having a new a new family with with very
young children all of that is just kind
of
adds to the weight of having to put a
book like this out but if we're able to
get rid of some of these obstacles with
the crowdfunding then i think
then you know it's like you know
like i mean i don't know if you can
imagine it like in a way this is my life
but like you wake up in the morning
and it's like you know you're just gonna
do the things that you love to do and
you're just gonna sit there and you're
gonna be able to like
to to have your mind free to think about
about about you know the next panels and
the next books and other exciting
projects so hoping we get there right
now we're doing okay like we're i think
what's like the third day is it and
we're we're at what like uh seventy
thousand i think yeah i think
close
so you know like the the the higher we
go the more
the more freedom it's going to afford us
because like i said i've said a few
times i'm not taking any money on this
myself all of the profits we get are
going to go to make sure that we can
keep doing this you know and that means
chord obviously it means uh meteor
definitely needs to get paid but for me
like with you guys you know with all the
with the patreon and the t-shirt sales
and everything
for now i'm fine like i don't need i
don't need more money i just more
excited about getting this like let's do
this that's what i'm excited about
all right so let's see what do we got
here
so someone asked how close closely does
god's dog follow the golden legend
um
and so
there are some elements of the golden
legend which are going to be implied but
they're not they're not they're not
going to be uh too present there there
are a lot of things that are going to
appear in the story as even like single
panel
things which are going to refer to a
whole bunch of stuff as the story goes
along uh and we hope that some people
will be able to catch them um
m asks
my artistic
inspirations i answered that before but
really quickly jeff smith who created
bone and mike mignola
um
those are the big ones and then of
course there are lots more but those are
kind of my two big guys and it's great
because both of those artists they have
a uh
kind of
especially manolo there's something
about his art which is it's not i
wouldn't say that
it's iconic but there's something
medieval there's like it feels like in
mignola's work there's like a somewhat
of an adaptation of medieval aesthetics
into the comic world and uh so that
makes that influence very appropriate
you know for what we're doing
so yeah i'm definitely so so until like
for now it's looking great and uh the
coloring too is awesome so philip cart
how do you pronounce cartoon is that how
you pronounce his name
uh yeah i'm not sure i think it's
cartoon but i don't like the
pronunciation yeah he's been doing great
and he's
amazing yeah so we we also kind of we
kind of pointed him towards vignola's uh
that type of coloring like a more tonal
moody coloring and uh and he's been
great and i've had some professional
artists uh
point out how diverse the the coloring
is too how he really takes advantages of
the moods of the scenes but also even
the time of day where the scenes are
and there's also a relationship you know
between the time of day and the moods of
the scene
and so and so he he's able to really
kind of gather that into uh some really
some there are some scenes that are
almost like three colors you know and
it's like these intense these intense
contrast and then there are other scenes
which are just this like glowing fully
glowing daylight you know with all the
all the details and all of it going at
the same time so it's pretty exciting to
have someone doing color that is so uh
so versatile
yeah
um does mang josh the mover says this
main character grow beard
uh
it kind of comes and goes is the best
way to understand that isn't it
um not in the book in this book but in
the in the full story you'll see beards
come and go that's for sure
all right so quick question
sorry go for it i was going to say
someone wrote have you thought of
getting in touch with ethan van skyver
this is creeper weirdo
uh it would really help with your reach
look him up on twitter and say yes i am
someone in contact with ethan van skyer
but i think he's a very busy man he
reached out to me like three years ago
or two years ago
to be on his channel and then then he
kind of vanished then he reappears again
and he's like yo i can't believe i
dropped this and i'd like to do it again
and so yeah so if you know if you guys
tweet to him like tweet to ethan and say
we really want you to talk to to the
gods dog people i got a message from him
uh maybe about a week ago i send him a
copy of the book for him to look at but
he hasn't gotten back to me so i'm
hoping that happens that'd be cool
what are you gonna say cord uh
just uh andrew andrew k's question about
using this to bridge folklore to
christianity like ivan the wolf
and
to me
uh a really good outcome of this project
and and whatever comes from it would be
more people doing something like that
i've always had this
this dream of like someone opens an
animation studio just because they want
to do like a beautiful rendition of the
princess and the frog
you know and and just make that folklore
and just bring old rich folklore back to
life
and
i think that this is sort of a gateway
to things like that happening and i
would be really happy about that
definitely like it's interesting because
if you look at some of the the big ips
that have come out or the big these big
properties that have come out in the
past several years you know if you think
of things something like uh
um
like
disney did did the series i forget what
it was called but it was like all the
princesses and all these full chloric
characters kind of interacting with each
other there was a that that play in that
movie into the woods that was like this
dive into fairy tales and everything but
it's all so subversive it's all about
twisting and turning and flipping it
upside down uh and so i think that what
we're trying to do is to show people a
way
to without ignoring that without being
naive but to kind of take that thing and
flip it back uh and i think what court
is saying would be awesome for people to
kind of make very powerful and beautiful
versions of our folkloric stories um and
uh and even subtle ones like very subtle
and
and uh profound ones without falling in
without feeling like they have to
to make all the characters let's say
surprising you know in in that kind of
way and make it all twisted and stuff
yeah or make it steampunk or something
yeah exactly or yeah some kind of weird
some kind of weird play on it um all
right so it's the same it's saints
george on the dragon
but the prince is saved saint george wow
we're so awesome it's like okay yes yeah
whatever dude we got it we got that
story you know and they're like all
those types of stories we got them now
let's tell that let's tell the real
story in a way that's powerful and uh
and exciting all right and so so
ronwood499 says will there be a
translation coming out i wonder how the
far east would like it given their use
of christian symbolism and
animation-oriented culture
i'm definitely open to anything i just i
think we just have to go through things
one step at a time is really the way to
see this
so we'll also see what happens like i
think that you know as we get an excite
an excitement around it and if people
can generate excitement and kind of get
their friends to read it get people in
their church to read it you know all of
this if we can generate excitement then
we will also have offers which will
appear with that excitement you know
distribution authors uh offers offers
for translation because it's obviously
something which would be very dif will
become difficult to manage on our own at
some point and so hopefully we can have
enough power
to to kind of enter into distribution uh
discussions with people without having
to give up our creative or creative
rights or having to give up you know
control over these characters and over
the the story so
yeah
right so hamilton provencha 20
go get yourself a beer thank you
hamilton so hamilton is actually a
friend of mine from south carolina so
i'm happy to see him here that's pretty
cool
regan lodge is in the chat sweet
so regan lodge is going to have a a
pinup in the book so i'm really excited
he says proud day one backer so thrilled
to see god's dog shoot to the top of
indiegogo
we'll be starting work soon on my pinup
for the book jonathan so i'm really
excited about that because he is
definitely his style and you know the
type of characters that he does is just
perfect for what we're doing so i'm
looking forward to seeing
what kind of interpretation he uh he
comes up with and so we've we've got a
few pinups kind of in the works we have
one by matt kratz who has his own comic
called kyrie
which is a great comic it's it's great
because it actually strangely fits into
this whole story like this kind of this
kind of mythological world with like
this universal stakes he has a alexander
the great as this interesting kind of
character that i won't i won't spoil it
or anything but it's really it's a
really fascinating story so we're happy
to have him
uh and there's also for now there's
jesse white who um who illustrated a
book called diosvolt some people might
have seen it it was like uh
it kind of it was like a crusader story
half uh trolling half serious it's total
it's not it's a little hard to totally
understand like how serious and how much
of trolling it was uh but it was like
this story of a crusader night that
encounters these demons and beautifully
illustrated and the illustrations were
just
like just vintage kind of classic you
know 70s uh sword and you know those
kind of conan comics that we had you
know that that uh that rich linework and
everything so yeah so i'm excited to to
see that these artists are are yeah are
surrounding us and part of this so
that's great yeah jesse's uh prin or
pinup is amazing it looks like a barry
windsor smith horror drawing
really well done yeah so we're just yeah
so we're just super we're excited to see
where this is gonna go
um
all right so dino ramsey says if this
takes
off
jonathan will you still be carving and
so
that's the big question dino that's a
huge question i'll be honest with you if
you probably notice that i'm not posting
as many carvings as i used to uh just
because of everything else that's going
on this crowdfunding thing i've been
working on it almost full time for the
past two weeks because there's a lot of
background stuff that i've been doing
sending press releases you know doing
all this stuff setting up the campaign
doing all these things so uh so it takes
up a lot of time but um i'm hopefully
setting up a way
to be able to continue carving you know
like i i now i hire an assistant for
carving and i'm also hiring someone
full-time as an assistant for the video
stuff um and so i'm setting things up so
that i will still be able to continue
carving but it's becoming harder um yeah
i might have to make some announcement
about that about which projects i'm
going to choose and which i'm not going
to do in the past in the next
few weeks let's say
so so m asked if jordan peterson could
give a shout out to the project that
would be amazing
but i understand that it's not something
you can just ask for like that well he's
tweeted it you know twice and so that's
not bad you know
i don't know what else he could do right
now so
for me i'm pretty happy that he that he
did that
fs asks if there's a platform where
artists could participate in this new
creative movement
um i don't think so but there should be
one i think that someone could
put something like that together and it
would be so cool to see
artists illustrators animators just kind
of coming together and making stories
like this
just because they need to be made so
that would be really cool yeah one of
the things i'm doing as much as i can
and other people like neil that that you
saw in the chat before uh durpa robbins
is trying to create a kind of at least a
an
at least for now like an organic network
of people that are
that we feel are game changers that are
really good artists to be able to
communicate with each other and tell
each other about their product projects
like nicholas kotar you've seen there's
other people like vesper stamper who's
been on my channel
paul kingsnorth rodriguez there's a lot
of these different people and so we're
hoping to see more and more
people kind of uh come into this world
but it's important to understand that we
really need world-class stuff like we
really want this to to to not be
our wish fulfillment but to really be
the best that we can make it and so
we're being pretty tough about the
quality of what we want to kind of see
out there
but that's okay i know that it's tough
it's hard because it makes it it makes
it forces people to have to step up but
in some way that's what we need we
really need that to happen
but you could also see niches of this
type of community forming on already
existing platforms too yeah definitely
and and in a way it's it's good i think
people are also going to have to kind of
take that up on their own and there are
there are plenty of ways to have
communities now on discord and
on different platforms where you could
exchange drawings you can give each
other advice
and you know depending on what medium
you're working in um
so john jay henderson says have y'all
ever read the incal
have you ever read inkow
is that mobius yeah
i think
i think i've flipped through it once
there's too much mobius for me to
remember
i've read and not read yeah i have read
it i read it a long time ago and there's
that dog-headed character in it that's
one of the reasons why i was kind of
attracted to it at the time but that
it's not he's not like our thinker he's
not like our son christopher that's for
sure in terms of his he's kind he's like
a womanizer i remember he's he's kind of
a sleazy character in my memory yeah um
all right let's see
sorry i'm trying to catch up on reading
yeah comments here all right so so don
popescu says will you do nfts this is
the big thing i volunteer for
translation before i see the comic hope
it will reach eastern europe great work
and so
i am so i don't even know if i told
court about this yet
it's like okay so
so i am working on an nft
uh
project right now um now the question of
the nft is
i don't i don't like nfts in themselves
like i don't think that nft is something
that has uh
i think they can just be boring and
stupid but it can also be very
interesting and so what we're what i
want to do uh and but i still have to
ask to crystallize is i want to create a
kind of hierarchy of rarity in the nfts
which will not be arbitrary which will
be related to the content okay and so
this is my idea i'm not sure i'm going
to do this this is my idea my idea is i
want in the book there are
so we have the secrets of god's dog book
which is going to go into the symbolism
but there are also real
secrets in the book
there are patterns which most people i
think 99 of the people won't see like
even ciphers you could say and so
one of the things that i wanted to do is
to create an nft which would be
an nft which would be linked to a pdf
and that pdf would have an extra page at
the end which would be a kind of cipher
into the symbolism of god's dog
and that will
play out in all the books so when you
when you get that cipher it will give
you
an advantage in terms of interpreting
the story
that you'll find as the books go through
so now the person who's willing to buy
those nfts at different levels of kind
of secret you could say they can do
whatever they want with it if they want
to keep it to themselves they can do
that if they want to share it they want
to do a screen grab and then share it
that'll be up to them but this is the
idea that i have for nfts to kind of to
create a true rarity and not just an
artificial one um and so
that is the idea that i've got like i
said i'm like dropping this on you chord
right now but i mean maybe you can tell
me what you think about that idea
i didn't know what an nft was until
about three days ago so that's
right so those who don't know an nft is
a digital property and so basically you
you are able to have a it's on it it's
it's in the same world as crypto it's on
it's on the blockchain or whatever and
so there's a
you have a a key which tells you and
tells others that you own
a digital property um and so
there's a lot of stuff about that which
sounds just to me a little
useless like it's about prestige i guess
and it's about uh owning something which
is popular there's all of that going on
but we want to do it like the way that i
would like to do it is to really make it
related to content itself which is like
it's a kind of a diving into the content
and the key to content that other people
don't have so
anyways
um our blessed tribe says if the
crowdfunding keeps going great what
comes after this one could you please
expound on the best scenario of what you
hope this becomes all right
so
so if the crowd funding going it keeps
going great and we we let's say we reach
at least a hundred thousand i'm hoping
more to be honest just because i just
want us to feel
once we launch i want us to feel like we
don't have to think about money right
away right we just don't think about it
um so the best case scenario is we make
a lot of money and then cord
is able to quit his job
do this full time uh and then we launch
into
the next books uh we launch into the
second book let you know let's say at
full steam and already thinking about
the third book and then the other books
matter and i will meet and we will also
go back into the story
and see what it is that we can add what
are the threads that we can add how can
we make this even better than what it
was um and then we're just going to pump
the
the books out we're just going to try to
have them come on the market you know
not as soon as we can like to have them
out you know i don't know like once a
year twice a year
i don't know what's possible for like i
don't want to speak for him but the idea
would be to have them coming out more
regularly um
and then
and then ultimately use that also as a
as a opportunity and a proof of what we
can do to look more broadly at other
possible stories that could be told and
even something like including other
artists including other writers you know
just creating that that and bringing
that energy to our to others that we
think are worth the worth the time of
the energy and so
yeah that's what that's what uh that's
the that's the what about you chord how
do you see this
yeah i agree that is the best scenario
and that's what i hope for um i think a
very solid plan b it no matter what the
next books need to be coming out
more regularly once a year maybe twice a
year so if we didn't reach the ideal
scenario where i could devote all of my
time to it
i would still stay heavily involved and
we would probably include a couple more
people to just
help steam roll through these things so
either way
this is part of a
movement that's going to keep rolling
yeah because there is like if if ever we
really don't reach the amount we want
and then cord continues to do to work
then there there are ways to do comics
and and these are not we're not making
them up like there are ways to make
comics with several artists one can be
blocking the the blocking the
compositions for sure i'd want core to
do that and then if someone can do it
they might someone else can pencil
someone else can ink someone else can
color and uh if we do it right it can
still be very good um but these are
these things are not impossible like
many people have done them before and so
and so i think that that could be
a let's say an alternative solution but
the best solution is definitely for me
the best solution would be to have chord
at least do the pencils like completely
and then if we have someone inking and
coloring that could be fine but uh yeah
thank you because i do want to keep like
a like i do want to keep the
the tone of what we have and the also
the flow of what we have uh i'd like to
keep that all through
i agree
yeah
so what's your e change simpson as with
your eta for first edition to be out and
so my hope is that we ship in february
that's my hope but i mean who knows
exactly with covid and these insane
things like if there's if there are more
lockdowns if there are more
of these supposedly you know breakdown
in in supply chains like who knows
what's gonna happen i was talking to a a
graphic novelist a few weeks ago and uh
he told me he can't put out his book
because it's on a boat coming from china
and it's stuck somewhere and he doesn't
know when it's going to arrive and so so
but this is the best case scenario is to
have it out in february we'll we'll
release the nft one of the things i want
to do is release the nft before
as well
so that those who really want to read
the book will have an opportunity to do
so with the nft
um and then
around that time also if we see that
we're really struggling to release the
book because of some unforeseen
technical problem then we can release
the pdf a little bit earlier so that
people can kind of at least have that to
go on uh these things will be will be
seen as it goes but for now it's
february that's my idea i don't know if
you have a better idea but a chord but
that's the kind of word that seems
useful yeah yeah
all right so john g anderson says i hate
everything about nft but i will admit
jonathan's idea is intriguing i'll try
to stay open-minded so this is what i've
been trying because i actually also
don't like that whole nft thing uh but
then it's actually it's like i'm going
to say i'm going into crazy but there
are some nft schemes right now which
offer something else besides the nft
right there's something called the you
probably have heard of it the board the
board ape yacht club uh and it offers
membership into a club with the nft i
was like oh this is an interesting thing
so you don't you could offer something
else besides just the actual ownership
and so this is what led me down this
line so i think really that that's what
i would like to do like to also maybe
have a an exclusive call a cover i was
thinking of doing a cover myself for the
nft so that the the physical book would
have chords cover and then the nft would
have my cover that kind of stuff to have
more more exclusive content so
uh our blessed tribe asks if i live in
canada i do not i live in montana united
states
yeah you're a lucky man to live in
montana right now
yeah
it was strategic on my part good
strategy that's for sure
uh
andrea andrew camaro me asks any ideas
for additional stretch goals any stretch
goals where all backers of a certain
level can win
this would be a great motivator for
current backers to spread the word
that's a good idea i hadn't thought
about that you know i don't know like
what would people want the thing we want
to avoid is
a lot of
um a lot of crowdfunding campaigns have
basically like run aground because
people add too much stuff in them and
then
they end up having a logistical
nightmare to ship and to pack and to
make sure everybody gets the thing that
they need
and so there are many people that have
lost money on their crowdfunder because
of that so this is something that we
want to avoid so right now the way it's
set up is that
the book is comic book
[ __ ] the comic book uh size book
the the secrets of god dog is the same
shape and the print is also the same
size and shape so that they can just all
be stacked together put in a mailing
envelope and sent out and so
we would have to find something which
would be
which would be uh reasonable but i like
someone's mentioned like the idea of
having a hundred thousand dollar uh kind
of perk or stretch goal we have to think
about it like maybe court and i can talk
about it and see what we could uh what
we could come up with
yeah
i mean what would people want like if
this is your chance guys we're here with
you guys like what would you want as a
i'm not saying we're going to do it but
maybe we can at least hear people's
opinions of what they'd like in terms of
a 100 000
uh
stretch goal or perk let's say
nico asks where's the link if he's
asking for the link to our campaign just
go to godsdog.com and it will forward
you to the uh
indiegogo page
yeah so we we bought god's it seems
someone had a website called godsdog.com
before so we had to buy it from somebody
which is like the most surprising thing
uh
all right so santiago diaz says how
about if the campaign makes a lot of
money let's say a hundred fifty thousand
two hundred thousand
could you make available to all tiers a
little print of your saint christopher
carving smaller than the fifteen dollar
one hmm
i don't know about that it's pretty
precious
well think about it but those are ideas
like those are good ideas you know
there's a good idea someone says a
teaser for book two oh that's an
interesting idea
that's an interesting idea that's an
interesting idea actually it's so so
let's see well it also depends on how
much work we can get done you know
before we print it but that could be a
funny little idea of having like a
a four page like a little just a little
fold up of uh
of what's coming uh good call lucas
vieira
that
blue herring says more writings from
material yeah we'd love that i would
love that that's for sure
um
so and the saint christopher print
that's why i'm saying like i'm not gonna
offer that to anybody else
and
i'm actually that carving i'm going to
keep for myself i decided not to sell it
it was in a show in new york a few
months ago
and
and
i haven't gotten it back yet from new
york but as soon as i get it back it's
gonna go in my office i'm not gonna sell
that i actually own none of my carvings
by the way but this one i've decided to
keep and so when you get that print then
it means you you'll have a you'll have a
pretty exclusive thing because i'm not
going to sell it and i'm never going to
sell the print again after this
crowdfunding
yeah so runwood says uh yeah says 100k
gold sketches from book two yeah that's
what we're thinking yeah
uh
who by the way renault is you if you
want to know renault is the guy who's
been really helping me with
understanding crypto and nft and is
helping me with my facebook ads and so
he's been doing an amazing job just i'm
just really happy to to have him around
and to be to be working with them he he
runs a marketing company he does he does
great work but um are we planning to
have interviews that definitely i would
love to um but for now yeah like
the crowdfunding's still two months and
so i really wanted to focus on the
actual thing that we can do with you
guys and with the the people that are
already following me and the fans and
you know all of that uh to start off
with and then you know starting like
next week i'll start sending press
releases uh and try to uh to get into
contact with other people that would be
willing to talk about it so definitely
that's probably gonna be coming if we
can get the attention
of people and so if you know of people
that would be willing to interview us if
you have if if you know of channels that
you that talk about comics or popular
culture or uh christian culture that you
think are you know that are big enough
that are worth the
the attention then yeah reach out to
them tell them about what we're doing um
you know so that if they ever do get an
email from me they'll already have heard
the buzz a little bit
in simpson yes i think a 13 year old
would like this book definitely i think
so too yeah
golden thread for five dollars says
james poulos upcoming book release
should prove instructive for execution
with respect to nfts
i don't know who that is i will look
i'll look that up
i'm kind of lucky because i i have i
have some good people around me that are
now that are kind of interested in
crypto and and all that stuff so i did a
i did actually did an interview with vin
armani which i haven't put out yet uh
which is going to come out yet yesterday
i was on robert breedlove's uh meaning
of money uh podcast which will probably
come out soon and so it's like all of a
sudden i'm more surrounded by uh
by crypto stuff so yeah
um
so now there's a lot of questions um
yeah they're rolling in they're rolling
in
so how large are the san christopher
prince they're the size of the comics we
don't want we don't first of all we
don't want them folded we want them to
be flat and then and and we want the
packing to be simple so that it's
already so expensive it's like i when i
when i started looking into the shipping
i couldn't believe how expensive the
shipping was and a lot of people in
europe especially are are disappointed
to look at the 25 shipping tag but i i
really looked into it and i looked at
what everybody else is doing uh and
that's really the standard so if we
don't want to lose money we don't have a
choice but uh so we don't want to add on
top of that other crazy stuff which
would which would be nuts
um
so i'm hoping like i know people in
europe like you know if you if you the
book is too expensive for you at this
point you can get the pdf at least you
can read the pdf uh you know and who
knows maybe in a year or so it'll be on
amazon and you can buy it there but
there's no we don't know like we don't
know how that's gonna play out it might
be it probably maybe a different edition
who knows right now we're focusing on
what we're doing right now
um ron wood says 200k go also maybe some
idea sketches for a saint nicholas santa
storyline
yeah i already have some sketches of
that i don't know if i don't i don't
know if court has seen them himself but
uh that'd be cool it's a great because
in the the idea of the saint nicholas
so i'm why am i giving you my ideas
someone's going to steal it from you but
that's i don't care i got enough i got
so many ideas it doesn't matter so like
the idea of this nicholas story is the
idea that we merge
the scandinavian imagery
with saint nicholas
and so we have a greek kind of christian
character with a
scandinavian uh character and then we go
really into like the intense stuff which
is that you know there's a really
controversial character in the saint
nicholas lore who's called swarthy pete
or or dark pete or black pete uh and so
like my idea was to make him an actual
ethiopian person who was kidnapped by
the scandinavians and so there will be
this whole ethiopian thread because you
know i love you guys know i love
ethiopian christianity so like this
whole ethiopian thread would have been
in this story of of saint nicholas like
in a scandinavian setting you know
becoming santa claus so anyways that's
the idea so yeah i mean i i would love
to tell that story it's a it's also i
think
an epic an epic story not as epic as
this one but epic as well
[Music]
uh yes the original artwork is
hand-drawn
um so we're offering pencil pages and
inked pages so
at different tiers yeah and so this is
the chance to or to like own a piece of
history i'm telling you like
this is going to be i'm telling you like
i really believe though this is this is
the this is like the the the outset of
something that's going to change like we
we are we're at the crux and we've been
seeing it like i'm not it's like i said
it's not just me it's the dirt the whole
jordan peterson thing you know this
whole kind of weird slew of 20 something
year olds that are suddenly going to
church that are suddenly being curious
about their christian roots you know all
of this is happening you know and uh and
so this is this is part of it like we
also need
stories and so you know this i i do
think that that
yeah
yeah i don't want to i don't want to to
to my own horn any more than that but i
think i think that it's definitely a
good investment to buy chords art right
now
uh chris pearlberg asked a good question
uh
does do graphic novels have a particular
strength for telling this story and to
me it does because as i was saying to
jonathan earlier when
uh the symbolism for me it's about
images they kind of map onto each other
so like
saint simeone's pillar
visually maps onto saint george's sword
and visually maps his maps onto
the hill of the garden of eden and and
jonathan's image of everything and there
are a few places in this book where i
took advantage of that and kind of
visually compared
images of some of those things
to to kind of hit that on the nose that
they were symbolically
linked i guess you would say
yeah that's what's amazing about a
graphic novel or is that you can create
a kind of visual poetry
you know by creating rhymes you know you
can create visual rhymes like i've
talked about this in terms of church
architecture where in the in a
traditional orthodox church you'll have
all these different icons up on the
walls and in the way they rhyme with
each other and so you have let's say an
image of the of christ as a child in the
eastern wall in the apps with the mother
of god there then on the western wall
you'll have an image of of mary uh who
is
who is dying on her deathbed and so it's
like that type of so it's like the
raising of the sun the setting of the
sun all this imagery so in a graphic
novel you can do the same thing which is
that you can create
rhymes of images and so like i think
it's awesome and i think chord really
has an intuition for it and you can see
it when you're going through the book
like that's what i'm saying you can just
read it and not get any of it but if you
pay attention you'll notice that there's
already these rhymes and those these
rhymes will increase in crescendo
as we move into the next books because
some of the the rhymes that are there in
the first books will now repeat in
further books and there'll be this play
of imagery that's going to happen so i'm
really excited about that to me like
graphic novels
uh have a lot of potential in terms of
symbolic storytelling and there are very
few people that have been able to uh to
use it you know and the people that have
let's say like alan moore for example
like he's definitely been able to use
that but just for very subversive means
right he's like the he's definitely the
anti-gods dog like he
he he also has these this
like his his um
his constantine character right from
swamp thing is uh is exactly what we're
dealing with it's like this
this christian lore christian
mythological world that he lives in but
it's completely dark and completely
cynical and completely uh nihilistic but
we're gonna set up a world like that uh
that isn't nihilistic so
right right
uh someone asked if i had seen the green
monk book uh the blood of the martyrs
and i did right as i started drawing
this book i literally have it on my desk
right now that's so good
yeah i've got it on that bookshelf over
there
uh
and when it came out i bought it
immediately and i thought if i could do
anything
close to how great this book looks i
would be very happy
so yeah it was an influence for sure
yeah yeah i like to meet him the the
artist i don't know if there's a way to
talk to him like i i
i really i think i know
i think i know some people who know some
people
who could get in touch with him yeah
let's get him on the channel i'd like
that that'd be cool
um
all right let's see what we got here
um so that saint nicholas story sounds
amazing something i have not yet figured
out draws me to saint nicholas and saint
christopher that's good they're great
saints there are they're good saints to
have now for sure
so sword master x in some of the preview
panels like not everybody's seen these
preview panels but patrons of mine have
seen these previews uh
say it says we see the adventuring party
singing hymns do the particular psalms
reveal parts of the story so that
particular hymn is is the story like
that hymn encapsulates pretty much
what the story is about but like i said
the way that core did it makes it even
more
about what the story is because you see
this barking dog which is interrupting
interrupting the hymn at the same time
uh which we had put in the screenplay
but when we wrote the screenplay uh we
didn't have the actual hymn we had um we
just had the idea that they would be
singing at him but we didn't have the
actual hymn and i don't remember who it
is that decided on this this if it was
myself or metsy or was it you court i
don't remember who it was it was it was
it was probably me different yeah so
it's probably me who decided unto him uh
but it was just so perfect like it just
it just really has all the story in it
so yeah
that is saint ephraim like can you go
anything can you go any wrong with
saneter and the syrian you know he
basically wrote he's behind my image of
everything and the whole image of
paradise comes from him so yeah
all right and so
i don't know i think we've probably it's
up to you but i think i think we're
we're good like we've been going for
about an hour and a half to me that's a
pretty good stream i'm not a i'm not a
three hour uh streamer so um
so guys i would just say you know
go back god's dog you know there are
plenty of ways to do it you know i there
has been some confusion with the add-ons
at the outset but now if you want to add
anything on you can do it right from the
first page you can just get you know
whatever you you if you already bought
things you can now go back and buy other
things from the the outset you can also
buy packages of books to save on
shipping i've reduced shipping on three
or four books
because i know it's it's frustrating to
buy one book and have to pay
the total shipping for each one
and so uh so yeah so there are different
ways to do it we're really excited about
where we're going we're excited about
where it is but we still obviously we
know it's gonna slow down now but we
need everybody that is excited about
this to keep the hype up so that we can
continue on and yeah why not make it to
a hundred thousand or two hundred
thousand i think by now a hundred
thousand like i just i feel pretty
confident we're gonna make it at least
there but why not two hundred thousand
and then
and then and then just just yeah then
turn on the the faucet and just start
start pumping out culture so so thanks
anybody so court is there anything you
wanted to tell people before we uh we we
go
uh just i'm very grateful thank you i
mean
i'm grateful for the opportunity to work
on something that i think is really
important and i'm
i'm just shocked and very thankful for
all the support that we've got so far
and it's there's something too about
like this idea of synchronicity and all
of these elements kind of coming
together at the same time you know in a
certain way
if you think like it's it seems so odd
when i
when i consider that you know i wanted
to work with you based on two pages that
i saw on your website
and uh but it's like i don't think we
could have had a better artist in the
situation like matsuri also couldn't
believe it mature kept saying that she
kept telling me this is exactly what i
saw in my mind like i don't know where
is chord how is it the chord is
nailing it in terms of the characters
their movements uh you know their their
dynamic and uh
and so yeah so we're really excited
about that and you know all the all this
kind of excitement about lord of spirits
and about giants again and about you
know monsters all of this is there so
you know like 10 years ago most people
didn't even know about all these giant
traditions but now it's like it's kind
of coming out and it's back out there so
so everybody thanks you for your time go
go if you haven't yet um
backed it go back it uh we're really
excited to see where we go with this and
so thanks everybody and uh yeah stay
tuned for more videos i am putting out
another video probably tomorrow which is
now going to be
you know i've talked about saint
christopher just a little bit here and
there but now i'm actually putting out
like a half an hour video where i'm
going to really dive into the symbolism
of saint christopher himself um you know
kind of based on the articles that i
wrote but a few more things in there as
well so stay
stay tuned for that everybody
and so bye bye see you soon
thanks guys